[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de paf
où nous allons traiter d'une actualité
qui était essentiellement politique vous
le savez avec les interventions
notamment du président de la république
à la télévision et pour en parler alain
gournac bonjour vous êtes sénateur
honoraire aux eti sénateurs désignent
chercher nateur ancien sénateur vous est
vrai beaucoup combattu notamment dans
vos mans bat pour l'égalité homme femme
s'était dès 12 ans de combat voilà nous
entrons pas là dessus
à côté de vous attirer de bezina bonjour
pour que nous allons signer le droit
public droit constitutionnel aussi à
l'université de florence mercadé bonjour
vous êtes avocate au barreau de
versailles à patrice et vous êtes en
grève peut-être non non j'aime bien
qu'ils sont rares aujourd'hui entière
jonchère lajaunie qui fait partie de la
corporation des éditeurs qui ne sont pas
en grève au ghana pour le alors on va
commencer peut-être avec la halle ce
qu'on pourrait appeler la stratégie de
communication du du président de la
république qui a deux interventions il
ya d'une jeudi au 13h de tf1 avec jean
pierre pernaut
il y en a une dimanche face à edwy
plenel et jean jacques bourdin sur sur
bfm tv donc deux stratégies très
différentes peut-être avant d'aborder ce
qui a été dit jeudi
comment comment on peut expliquer cette
stratégie aussi différentes et aussi
rapprochée c'est assez rare une
communication est comme ça de
communication de suite d'un président de
la république
moi personnellement je suis très étonné
c'est des communicants qui lui disent de
faire 2 td quand on a pas vu qui vous
dépasse paix devant wii que respectable
critiques il ne parle pas il envoie son
premier ministre ont passé mais nice et
il fait un constat vis-à-vis de son
premier ministre que la communication
n'est pas bonne sortant de leur bouche
et donc alors qu'il aurait fait hier
qu'il avait hier bond de près on la
république donc mais qui phase 2 de deux
interventions sauf ça étonnant et et et
en pur communicants et je trouve qu'ils
que c'est trop rapprochées et c'est trop
d'un seul coup ça fait un peu panique ça
faire ça va pas bien que ça fait un peu
bon des choses vont pas bien alors il
faut il faut occuper le terrain moi j'ai
mon avis et en plus mais alors et la
mousse est assez étrange parce qu'on
pourrait en effet se dire il avait prévu
l'intervention sur tf1 puis après son
doublé s'est passé bien il faut faire
une autre mais on peut pas considérer ça
je pense de la part du pouvoir sur le
dire c est tout ça est calculé ne semble
pas que cela c'est de la cenap ne semble
pas que ça soit d'improvisation ça
paraît tout à fait intelligent puisque
le nommer le le choix de des deux
journalistes que ce soit jean pierre
pernaut et bourdin c'est pas du tout
deux stratégies de communication ces
camps à peu près la même cible sur des
choses différentes je veux dire bourdin
comme jean pierre pernaut sont les deux
journalistes les plus vilipendé les plus
critiqués par l'intelligentia parisienne
par les autres journalistes on écoute
tout les ai toutes les chaînes de radio
et sont toujours la critique et pernod a
critiqué bourdin alors que ces deux
types qui ont probablement des défauts
et aussi beaucoup de qualités mais qui
parle franchement à ce qu'on peut
appeler la france profonde mais j'aime
pas tellement ça mais mais perdent
wilson populaire ou populistes et donc
c'est une douce est une très bonne idée
de la part de mâcon de dire ok là je
vais pas aller sur france inter un matin
je vais pas aller chez des et chez les
intellectuels j'ai pas chez les penseurs
j'ai pas chez v m
koubi d'abord il ya pour les raisons
qu'on s'aime et se décolle mais surtout
c'est une très très bonne idée
les artères c'est une très bonne idée
d'avoir d'abord choisissez cessé ces
deux personnes le journal d'aujourd'hui
après 10h30 plein et je pensais juste un
tout petit truc un peu pour pour
contrebalancer en plus mais c'est
peut-être pas très bien compris mais
est-ce que bourdin et pénales seront
ensemble parce que si bourdin et plenel
son ensemble c'est comme si plein n'est
pas là je pense que bourdin va écraser
alors annoncé bastien contraire je pense
pas parce que plein elle va s'énerver
tout de suite alors que je joue je
parierais sur bourdin un grand vainqueur
et puis ensuite c'était c'était une
troyes metz c'était une promesse de
campagne électorale de macron avait dit
je donnerai un interview à bourdin et à
plenel donc a donc il risque il a dit je
le respecte mais pour l'heure est donc
au concept mais ça va pas promise si je
lui ai dit voilà quand je cite si je
suis élu effectivement je donnerai tout
moi je crois que ce qui est recherché à
mon avis par emmanuel macron c'est cette
idée de viser tous les publics
il ya vraiment quelque chose
d'absolument universaliste dans cette
vocation c'est à dire je vais faire une
première communication à la papa avec
quelque chose d'un peu rassurant à la
campagne dans un service public en
visant un public 13h ou du coup je vais
pouvoir avoir du monde et j'ai visé
c'est même comme ça que c'est présenté
d'ailleurs que l'interview sur le sur le
site même de bfm aider et des radios et
des télés qui vont être présents pour
dimanche c'est les jeunes actifs c'est
le côté un petit peu plus jeune le plus
côté un petit peu plus contestataire
avec mediapart est donc finalement on a
le choix de deux médias de deux créneaux
qui sont complètement différent pour
essayer aussi de montrer que emmanuel
macron n'est pas le fameux président des
villes n'est pas le technocrate qu'on
craint et moi je crois que justement on
parie sur le fait de taper le plus large
possible pour essayer d'avoir un panel
pourquoi la question posée à la grenade
pourquoi aussi reprocher parce que coco
qui peuvent être fiers comme pour bon
nombre un mois noir
je pense qu'aussi qu'aujourd'hui il ya
tellement de fractures là en ce moment
et de crise et de grève différents
métiers
alors que ce soit la justice ce n'est
pas que la corporation des avocats et
magistrats greffiers avocats
c'est il ya vraiment un vrai mouvement
tout à fait donc il ya ce mouvement
voilà au niveau de la justice et un
mouvement au niveau des jeunes et ça les
politiques et les de l'exécutif craint
beaucoup les mouvements des jeunes
notamment au niveau des universités
voilà il ya des grèves gare sncf etc
donc je pense qu'il faut qu'il arrive à
couvrir effectivement le panel le plus
large possible et probablement que ça à
cette stratégie de dire on en fait un
trésor où il ya une population
particulière en enfer le dimanche soir
de manière rapprochée par rapport à des
crises qui sont très rapprochés en ce
moment fait que ça c'est un peu comme ça
moi que je m'explique après c'est vrai
que ça n'explique pas forcément le
rapprochement rangement et un président
qui avait dit et ça donne l'image je
suis un peu d'accord avec vous ça donne
l'image ça veut donner une image
rassurante et au contraire ça pourrait
enfin moi je suis content de voir qu'il
ya quand même quelqu'un qui tient la
barque
enfin le chemin qui mène la barque que
j'ai un peu parlé non mais sur cette
stratégie communication c'est quand même
bien que le président de la république à
l'heure où je veux dire la france est
complètement immobilisé par une bd des
escouades de cheminots l'on sait pas
trop ce qu'ils veulent et c est que là
il ya quelqu'un qui intervienne qui ok
mais il y avait le c'est vrai que c'est
un peut-être un défiance vis-à-vis de
ceux qui parlent d'habitude c'est à dire
du premier ministe c'est à dire des
ministres offert de concerner le prénom
d'un public il faut quand même qu'on le
voit et qu'on entende enfin on a été élu
président de tous les français c'est je
vois rien de choquant au fait qu'il
intervient neuf ans puisqu'on wade
l'interné on parle du moment du
rapprochement entre les deux non ça
c'est encore puisqu'elle droite voilà si
le jury mais et après qu'il fasse perdre
pernaut puis bourdin je veux dire voilà
comme ça il aura touché en une semaine
un peu la totalité d'une certaine cible
est belle et c'est très bien oui il va
entraîner des gens vont venir écouter
macron parce qu'il ya it will edwy
plenel qui est si elle est l'abus
ploemel il serait il doit écouter face à
face attendu comme là bas et c'est pour
ma part d'un président il choisit après
tout c'est parce que ça pour le coup ça
n'a pas changé c'est toujours le
l'elysée le président de la république
qui choisit les journalistes qui
n'attend oui mais quand il est inquiet
du recul ça vous arrêtez vous pour
criticus
non non non il avait été candidat il
avait eu un face à face avec edwy plenel
de trois heures oui germain sur
mediapart qu'avaient été d'écouter
d'ailleurs très passionnant et ça
s'était plutôt bien passé ambitieux
j'aurais plainte un journalisme un
journaliste d'investigation médiapart a
lancé est qui et qui fait partie de
voilà deux choses qui je crois que le
président a envie de montrer qu'il n'a
pas peur aussi un petit peu de lucidité
voilà tout à l'heure parce qu'ils
étaient des sujets qui n'ont pas été
abordés avec jean pierre pernaut qui
souffrent d'avoir d'autres pensent à la
laïcité qu'il teinte qui est un des
leurs est le cheval de et l'horreur
c'est leur sujet on va revenir peut-être
à cette première intervention au fond le
on pourrait dire que le thème principal
c'est je ne céderai pas le leur je ferai
ce que je ferai ce que je suis ce que je
dis j'ai fait ce que j'ai fait ce que je
faisais
jusqu'au bout c'est ça d'une part il n'a
pas cédé certains peuvent en tout cas
moi titre personnel c'est ce que
j'attendais c'était un peu paniquée à
l'idée que comme beaucoup d'hommes
politiques depuis 40 ans à chaque fois
que la voilà mais c'est à chaque fois
c'est on se dit bon ça y est ok il prend
la parole il va ya bon j'ai compris le
malheur des cheminots etc
on va se remettre autour de la table
puis on verra les la réforme on la fera
dans dix ans quand on sera d'accord
donc là pas du tout et donc ça c'est
extrêmement rassurant de voir que on a
quelqu'un qui tient le qui mène les
opérations donc ça c'est bien
ensuite il était assez didactique et
c'était très bien vu la cible sur le
l'histoire de la csg fans de peu pour
les pour les retraités
c'était un discours extrêmement clair
pas pas de langue de bois et puis on
avait l'impression enfin moi s'il m'a
donné l'impression de quelqu'un qui sait
parfaitement où il va ce qu'il veut
faire et je n'ai pas l'intention de
m'arrêter bouaké ont fait des réformes
on est là on reconstruit la maison et je
trouve ça plutôt plutôt bien donc sur le
fond c'est vrai qu'il ya pas une grande
annonce mais c'est justement c'est ce
qui m'a rassuré c'est que j'avais peur
qu'il ait une annonce en disant on va
ces débats n'en est donc pas l' annonce
est maintenant mieux donc pas de pas de
reculade
c'est une bonne stratégie d'ailleurs de
dire ce qu'il a dit est ce qu'avait dit
le premier ministre trois journaux
dimanche j'irai jusqu'au bout
je pense que c'est une bonne chose il
faut changer tout dans la maison
bon il me la voix de la gauche la voix
de la droite tout ça c'est terminé
tuez moi pardon oui mais je crains tu
républicain j'ai toujours respecté prise
et on aurait pu bonifier
je souhaite que le président de la
république régis bien sûr parce que
sinon j'aime et je n'ai même pas mon
pays et je vais pas mener tout combat de
ma vie pour essayer de servir le mieux
possible avec les erreurs c'est certain
et globalement de tenir le choc en
particulier je dis ici parce que peut
être qu'on soit courageuse en face de
ces grèves sncf
oui c'est une bonne chose aussi que
c'est un peu ce qui était attendu de lui
un tue-le tue-le dit
assez bien il a donné ce style depuis sa
candidature à la présidentielle ce style
de fermeté il a dit si je suis élu je
serai le capitaine du navire je veux
réincarner les dorures de la république
on a vraiment eu le sentiment que ça
allait être un président qui décide
plusieurs fois il a donné aussi un
discours un petit peu lyrique en disant
libérez protéger une hymne il a voulu
endosser la responsabilité de quelqu'un
qui a la foi dessinée qui a conscience
aussi de cet enjeu national de ce
regroupement autour de sa personne et je
crois que voilà pour le coup n'a
vraiment fait ce qu'on attendait de lui
redonner il a fait ce qu'il a dit et
même dans ce style là il l'affirmé
depuis début je trouve assez fidèle
finalement à son image c'est à dire une
image de fermeté une image peut-être qui
peut lui coûter aussi un petit peu parce
que d'ailleurs quand on entendait les
micros oui c'est vrai c'est la première
vague quand même la composition première
vague ses côtés un peu autoritaire qui
peut maintenant un petit peu lui coûter
mais en tout cas il va au bout de ce
qu'il a dit il tenait à avoir cette
image de fermeté il l'a tenu jusqu'au
bout en tout cas pendant toute
l'interview d'hier même l'argumentation
sur la csg a mis les personnes âgées et
des retraités le nom à mon travers ça y
est vous dire c'est profond c'est pas du
tout avec qu'il a dit hier surtout de la
dir est bien engagé vous écouter dans ma
ville des retraités il irait presque
plus de vie associative ci avait pas les
retraités les jeunes retraités qui
veulent pas dire qu'ils sont très
heureux de donner encore après avoir
donné deux matches il faut résister ça
et ça là c'est juste que vous dire que
ça passe mal justement on va revenir
peut-être sur le retour est ce qu'il ya
un retour à l'autorité de l'état on le
voit avec eux justement belle sncf
on l'a vu avec l'évacuation de sorbonne
on le voit avec les analystes
est ce que c'est
on semble comme ça je sais pas c'est une
question que je pose mais que l'autorité
de l'état mais peut-être étaient bafoués
dans les années précédentes et qu'elle
serait peut-être de retour est évident
il est évident que je par exemple
j'imagine très mal emmanuel macron avec
léonard da se dire je pense que il que
lui aurait traité les choses devaient
attendre avec un petit peu plus et les
abriter je pense qu'avec cette petite
vague tout est dit c'est à dire que on a
2 2 présidence qui sont totalement
différentes et on parlera de cette vidéo
issue pense qu'il peut pas faire moins
que de regretter
non mais c'est vrai que et c'est vrai
que il ya eu ce référendum par exemple
sur l'aéroport de notre dame des landes
et puis qui n'a été suivi d'aucun
d'aucun effet on a eu l'impression quand
même pendant des années qu'il y avait
peut-être un relâchement de l'autorité
de l'état non moi je pense que oui si
vous voulez des qu' il y avait une très
grosse manifestation très grosse
manifestation
on sentait que tout ça était très
organisée même si ça se faisait dans
notre dos moi je crois qu'il veut aller
jusqu'au bout et qu'il n'a pas terminé
parce que là vous parlez vous perdez une
réforme de l'état tient fils à l'épaule
à la retraite retraite et je reste
persuadé que c'est la stratégie des deux
ans oui moi la somme ferdinand j'y crois
parce qu'on peut faire évoluer les
choses avec difficulté mais on peut
faire bien après ce sera beaucoup plus
difficile donc il le sait et il va
avancer dans ce à dire je re culture la
maison je remets en place la france et
je repositionne
la feria la france des années
d'étrangers et qui voyagent énorme et
vous a écouté l'image de la france pays
des îles de considère comme un leader
oui c'est ça oui on en avait parlé et il
y a deux avantages à faire les choses
vite c'est quelle est la légitimité qui
est encore forte
et puis que on peut on peut connaître
peut-être les premiers résultats de la
politique parce que c'est long d'avoir
des résultats de la politique avant
avant éventuellement une réélection il
ya quand même cela il aurait jadis comme
dessus ça c'est clair
j'adore sa stratégie oui je les ai pas
parlé avec lui j'ai parlé d'autres
choses mais pas que ça et je vais vous
dire je reste persuadé qu'ils doivent
est dans la période où parce que c'est
un homme qui veut que les choses aillent
vite
il voudrait bien commencé à voir des
résultats apparaître de façon à pouvoir
continuer c'est cette ligne de réformes
et à 10 2% de croissance il a essayé de
tout si un président égyptien
un président qui est un petit peu de
chance aussi c'est ça qui est
merveilleux non mais faut appliquer mis
sur la piste bien sûr on peut critiquer
hollande à mellila des effets ont été
blessés chacun par deux sens avec ma
femme accro il s'éteint présence en rond
pour l'instant même si même si la
croissance est plutôt plus faibles que
le reste de l'europe ont été requis et
attention moi je le dis en grès
attention autorité et autoritarisme prix
attention c'est sa rifle à limay et
imiter les tenues étaient en effet il
faut pas qu'ils donnent l'impression
oui par exemple les députés ont des
feuilles pour savoir ce qui ils ont à
voter dans la journée
moi j'ai jamais vu ça et j'ai 30 ans de
carrière j'ai jamais vu sa valeur vous
voterez pas vous faites pas ceci paraît
là oui il faut quand même que le député
ou de sénateur et est une responsabilité
personnelle et d'enseignants en garde
les impôts côté godillots cui
vous aviez une expérience très
importante et beaucoup de vos confrères
ou consorts avaient la même et exige
enfin expérience alors que là ce sont
des nouveaux ce sont des jets aux siens
à la station voilà vous ne voyez pas la
critique
j'avais raison puisque dire c'est que
vous dire que c'est toi qui devons-nous
analyse que je les regarde et écoute il
faut rajouter un petit prince sur la
discipline majoritaire que vous que vous
décrivez par rapport au groupe en marche
c'est pas rassurant que parce que ce
sont des nouveaux députés on soit obligé
de leur donner des ordres de fin des
formes de consigne de vote
ou en tout cas des manières d'agir qu'il
faut savoir quelques-uns au début au
début de la législature que oui mais
juste dans un bureau avant pour les
voilà qui n'est pas rassurant parce que
c'est ce qu'ont choisi des jeunes
députés pour les diriger du coup ça
pourrait donner une mauvaise image du
pouvoir sachant qu'à mon avis au
parlement emmanuel macron est un peu en
train notamment avec sa réforme
constitutionnelle d'annoncer une forme
d'autoritarisme plus wii 2 2 peut-être
un petit peu risqué notamment par
rapport aux droits du parlement et qui
peut lui donner une mauvaise
contrairement à la rétention oui
grandissent et les pouvoirs du parlement
pour les autres la communication des
paroles mais pour les amendements les
amendes
ce astrologique de dire ben moi je vais
organiser les amendements ray et c'est
le propre de notre enfer moi avons été
au niveau de la communication c'est
probablement pas les des seigneurs il ya
encore des choses à il ya du monde il ya
des équipes ya des porte paroles à
droite porte parole à la boutique vous
voilà mes deux des délices de communique
aux côtés du président ou même du seul
monde du président de l'assemblée
nationale
ce sont des gens extrêmement compétents
alors parfois je suis étonné parce que
c'est pas important ce que vous émettez
c'est la perception de ce qu'est ce que
vous émettez c'est d'ailleurs le plan de
communication d'emmanuel macron qui
avait dit quand il a été élu
j'expliquerai je serai pédagogue et face
à des contestations je je je
surveillerai toujours la communication
attention peut-être à ne pas briser la
ligne entre l'autorité et rétablir les
deux regroupements remarque d'ailleurs
ça il ya quelques dissensions et
quelques explications et ça se passe pas
toujours aussi bien du fait qu'il y en
ait un qui refuse d'avoir des réseaux 6
partie des 1 qui viennent de gauche
c'est là qu'ils reviennent de droit qui
refuse et qu'ils arrêtent en voilà et
qui entendent dans la rue grecque le
fond ou d'irlande est bon alors il ya
d'ailleurs pour la septième j'ai appris
qu'il y avait quand même un groupe
majoritaire mais important qui
s'inquiètent de l'évolution de la grève
et cette série des lieux violent et
justement alors est-ce que ça parce qu
on est dans une configuration où on
voyait le pouvoir il ya les syndicats et
on n'entend pas tellement les
oppositions il n'y a pas beaucoup
d'opposition est ce que c'est pas un
problème quand même la voir faire - oui
non mais non jamais c'est vrai dans non
mais c'est pas une bonne c'est pas une
bonne situation grâce à un temps je lui
ai dit d'en cerner leurs quelque chose
qu'il peut déclarer je lui ai dit dans
une discussion je lui ai dit nous on
votera tout ce qui vous ferait du bien
les textes qui nous plaît on essaiera d
améliorer ensemble nous et nous met
leurs rails ce qui nous pose à votre a
pas mais il ya toujours eu une majorité
une opposition
alors nos maux position allait peut-être
pas le bon moment pour nous parce qu'on
voit bien ça veut dire quoi quand il
fait bien sûr posé les bons et il ya
l'intérêt du pays mais
il m'a pas répondu mais je reconnais
qu'ils manquent consonnes faiblesse
terrible le parti socialiste mszp
d'existence les nerfs et puis je te
continuer à laisser les insoumis sont
pas d'accord ils se la vie s'en vont
donc la politique de la chaise vide
c'est pas non plus ce n'est pas une
vraie enfin voilà non mais c'est vrai
qu'il peut poser un problème même de la
démocratie pour la démocratie parce que
le fait qu'ils de position politique ça
me permet justement d'apaiser les
tensions
il faut bien évidemment qui est une
opposition en tout cas que l'opposition
se réveille et se structurer et qu'elle
apparaisse en tant que tel mais l'a par
exemple sur le ce que vous évoquez sur
problème de la sncf on peut tout à fait
comprendre qu'il ait pas d'opposition
puisque à priori tout le monde est
d'accord pour cette réforme fera tout
sauf sauf les cheminots mais quelle
serait la part de l'opposition à les
critiquer cette réforme que tous nos
appels
mais voilà on appelle de ses voeux bah
si c'est pour ça que là pour une fois je
trouve que c'est cette certaine
unanimité de la classe politique david
est le problème de la sncf est plutôt
agréable et plus structurellement en fin
de saison
c'est important qu'ils aient c'est
important il ya konan ali yahia
il n'y a pas grand monde ça peut poser
problème au pouvoir lui-même
enfin et c'est pour ça que lui dis parce
que je pense que c'est important que le
président de la république
ch alors attention sur une opposition
intelligente oui parce que les français
en ont marre aussi
comme il est comme on n'est pas pour lui
on est content qu'ils ont fait contre
toulouse mais charte est fini ce temps
là est terminée je partage un peu la vie
de jean charles je crois que tout de
suite après le 13 heures jean luc
mélenchon y est allé de son twitt chacun
est allé voilà être dans l'opposition
systématique en disant de toute façon
tout ce qu'il a dit n'est que du vent on
retrouve l'autoritarisme de ce président
donc l'opposition politique est quand
même là malheureusement pour son rôle de
critique mais après il faut bien
distinguer opposition politique et
finalement opposition syndicale rôles de
l'opinion reus la politiquement je suis
pas sûr qu'il y avait forcément un rôle
à jouer au niveau de l'opposition
politique parce que finalement ce texte
de loi en tant que tels si on doit
parler techniquement n'est pas
particulièrement discutés ou n'a pas en
tout cas deux pointsde accroche dans
l'opposition
et souhaite moi je suis membre d'une
famille qui est pas toujours facile à
suivre tout le monde sera d'accord
là-dessus mais je suis dans ma famille
je reste dans ma famille et j'essaie de
faire évoluer ma famille dans la bonne
direction
voilà et la bonne direction c'est pas
d'opposition systématique au président
de la république président de la
république a été élu alors il ya parmi
les conflits à ceux des étudiants et
c'est bien ça va même si les vôtres sont
assez pour ceux qui connaissent vraiment
je les salue d'ailleurs tout se passe
bien à l'université droit c'est vrai que
néanmoins bon on a aussi écho quand même
de tout ce qui se passait mal autour de
nous notamment l'université de paris ix
un don dont je viens et qui a été voilà
pas mal de centres qui ont été l'honneur
voilà des bourses sorbonne l'occupant du
diamant de nice étaient 19 12 et 15 ans
et 20 sur 20 il ya un collectif
d'enseignants risque est terriblement
que les étudiants du des conneries on
est habitués se dire c'est presque rire
en cette saison le dépasse et qui se
respecte c'est consubstantiel du statut
mais que des enseignants se joignent à
eux pour dire on réclame une note
politique de 20 sur 20 aux examens enfin
c'est totalement abérrant là je veux
dire que cette bêtise et pu sortir de
l'enceinte universitaire voir aller
jusqu'à nous faire ça totalement idiot
c'est à dire non à la sélection c'est
bien
c'est bien ça pour le coup est ce que
mais c'est pour les pour les pouvoirs en
place est toujours très en vue et les
mollahs la jeune dj gouvernement fait
très attention à la jeunesse oui
monsieur occupée au moment du cpe riddle
et des nuitées jour je peux dire que
j'étais pas seul
c'était pas mal mais j'étais dans la
négociation avec les avec ces jeunes
avec des jeunes talents aussi j'ai
rencontré des jeunes talents oxygène
avait pas d'accord at-il ont bien changé
comme un regard des biens du côté de la
jeunesse si ça dérape ya un blessé s'il
ya de la ferme à l'ipo ces jeux je pense
et il le fait mais je regarderai
sérieusement cette affaire pour qu'il
n'y est pas en plus ils sont en train de
casser ils ont cassé cette nuit ils ont
cassé le bureau international sait pas
dans quelle université
les deux bureaux des contacts
internationaux traitement kcc c'est pas
bon oui toutes les structures en règle
générale en ressorte dégradé il ya des
occupations ya alors je crois néanmoins
que la grève
d'ailleurs je crois que la grève à la
sncf et des ailes et risqué mais bon
voilà la cgt on a va partir ou se faire
un peu près cela appartient au moment où
le président essayait de dire voilà je
n'oppose pas les français je suis aussi
du côté des cheminots voilà il ya une
optique de conciliation qui peut se
faire
c'est vrai que le mouvement étudiant est
beaucoup plus risqué je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec vous notamment parce que
finalement on n'arrive jamais à
connaître le début et la fin de ses
revendications
parce que séné du nouvel algorithme
parcours sup qui finalement reprend un
petit peu les défauts de l'ancien
algorithme qui était apb c'est à peu
près la même chose
certains y voient une sélection même pas
complètement sûr que ce soit l'objectif
de cette nouvelle réforme mais bon ça
part de là et on ne sait pas jusqu'où ça
va parce que finalement certains se
revendique aussi de la zad en disant
voilà c'est une
c'est un autre moyen que nous
on va très loin la certification voilà
et on a vu que voilà le cpe aller dans
le débat législatif c'est pas forcément
beaucoup mieux parce que finalement bon
ça peut se solder par une vraie rupture
avec l'opinion essayez de donner droit
alors il ya eu l'optique de gaulle qui
en 68 a dissous l'assemblée nationale
pour essayer de donner une assise
politique finalement à ceux à ce
mouvement là je crois pas que ça soit
vraiment une contestation politique dont
je crois pas que ça serait utile mais
voilà il faut pas perdre le contact avec
cette population
je crois que on a connu une jeunesse un
peu coupé en deux parce que il me semble
qu'il ya peu de choses en commun entre
les les quelques dizaines d'étudiants
qui sont là à réclamer des 20 sur 20 des
examens qui sont là pour on ne sait pas
trop pourquoi et puis quand même
heureusement toute une jeunesse qui trie
qui travaillent qui a envie d'innover
qui fait qui fait des études dans des
dans des parcours peut-être plus nouveau
plus intéressants qu'ils essayent de
deux d'innover de faire plein de choses
en impression que c'est cette jeunesse
là n'a pas comme seul objectif d'avoir
la sécurité de l'emploi à vie son petit
pavillon de banlieue et ses acquis et
voilà les jeunes absents qu'il ya une
jeunesse qui est vraiment explosé donc
je pense que les les trois cinquièmes de
la jeunesse française sont tout à fait
il intelligent passionnant et c est que
là on a on a on a créé on a une vision
complètement tronquée de de la jeunesse
qui n'est pas la chaîne française s'est
passé s'est passé jamais quand on lit la
la banderole pour le droit à l'éducation
dit non à la sélection objectivement
avant la réforme
il y avait une sélection à l'université
c'est à dire que de ramadhan descendent
mois des sens
au mois de décembre la moitié des amphis
été vidé et c'était et valeur et donc la
sélection elle existe depuis toujours
faim moi j'étais à la fac il ya fort
longtemps mais on voyait bien qu'il y
avait une sélection parce que des gens
se trompent et de filières et l'idée
aujourd'hui c'est justement de dire aux
gens d'aller dans la bonne filière et
pas de perdre leur temps sacha aller
faire du lui assigne les bouffer voilà
c'est ça ou ils n'auront pas de
dépendance où ils n'auront pas de
débouchés où ils y vont par défaut donc
je trouve que c'est
il y avait de la sélection est
qu'aujourd'hui au moins les choses sont
claires pas son nom oui mais y en avait
l'apb quand il n'y aurait plus de place
tirés au sort il y a toujours eu une
sélection mais qui étaient sur des
critères absolument se fait aussi après
signera à se faire et nos diversités
c'est aussi non et puis de proposer une
année de transition un jeune pour le
faire monter de niveau enfin je trouve
que c'est dû l'aider
il ya toujours eu des filières
sélectives telle la filière d imiter par
exemple qui dit depuis le début d'une
filière sélective ne rentre pas dans un
iut n'importe qui il ya des dossiers
dans l'ailé le corps enseignant regarde
les dossiers a dit cela on prend pas il
a le niveau là pas le niveau et c'est
donc ça a toujours existé
il me semble pas que les iut soit un
exemple même de la faillite de
l'enseignement on compterait sept c'est
une filière qui marche extrêmement de la
série qui délivrent des diplômes
vraiment intéressant c'est un bac + 2
après on peut continuer ses études on
peut s'arrêter fin je dire c'est un truc
tracé sélectif depuis le début et puis
on critique n'est pas de soucis trop
souvent l'université de ne pas savoir
former de ne pas savoir finalement
ensuite mené un rationnel et ce sont les
étudiants eux mêmes qui se plaignent de
sa d'avoir un tronc commun trop générale
de ne pas être finalement de ne pas
pouvoir faire autre chose de ne pas
pouvoir évoluer dans leur parcours donc
là c'est ce que parcours sur leur
propose je crois qu'ils ne savent pas
forcément toujours l'origine de leur
contestation dînatoire voilà où le sont
d'ailleurs nos vies
dans les interviews des explications
mais on sait pas très bien protestent
mais on conteste que ça ça a toujours
été ma toile est jeune et il avoue
retire mais ce nom à la sélection quand
même salle
c'est quand même très étonnant presque
que ça reste encore un slogan alors
qu'on sait très bien que les étudiants
ont pas envie de devenir des chômeurs et
c'est drôlement emploi donc ils savent
très bien qu'il faut surtout sélection
quand même enfin c'est quand même un un
vestige quoi presque c'est vraiment un
combat derrière savoir que je veux dire
c'est ce nom à la sélection quand même
et puis ça pour voir où sont les riches
les convaincre son jeu si bien que d'ici
si les trois cinquièmes
un travail joue ce matin j'ai appris
qu'ils étaient dans un bus un restaurant
qui est fermé et les profs sont venus
vous préparez des suspects et pour pas
rentrer pour pas avoir d'histoire et
pour préparer leurs examens
donc c'est des jeunes qui veulent
absolument que ça sortir c'est par le
haut ou non par le bas je rajoute que
évidemment il ya des étudiants qui
travaillent vous avez raison c'est
rassurant pour notre avenir à nous en
tant qu'enseignants et puis on a été une
petite équipe aussi à essayer de
continuer nos cours sur facebook live et
sur en essayant de tenter des techniques
en enseignant notre salon il ya beaucoup
d enseignants chercheurs qui ont fait ça
en tout cas
et ça prouve aussi que voilà pour ceux
qui ont envie de faire il ya toujours
moyen de d'apprendre et de continuer à
en tout cas enseigner il ya des gens qui
sont réceptifs ya des gens qui ont envie
de travailler
heureusement on est quand même là pour
eux et d'ailleurs les votes qui ont eu
lieu dans les universités sont plutôt
recontre live enfin sur alors même s'ils
sont contestés sur dix ans et de vote
électronique dont 4 enfin les votes que
le lieu sans décote
il va leur côté mais voilà
[Musique]
parce que je pense que c'est le résultat
qui fait alors autres mécontents pense
celui de l' elysée en justice des avk
notamment pour quelle raison alors alors
la raison général et philosophique c'est
qu'il y à un ressenti à maria des choses
qui sont bien dans la réforme
mais dans ce qui ne va pas et dans ce
qui choque c'est qu'il y à un ressenti
de la volonté de faire des économies sur
le dos des justiciables finalement enfin
sur le panneau des justiciables mais sur
le fait qu'ils seront moins bien traités
et de couper au maximum les relations
entre les justiciables et les juges
donc on a par exemple se passer le plus
possible se passe et jules du juge et
des avocats aussi du coup ne se passe et
oui essayer de se passer même de la
justice y avoir d'abord deux général si
on pouvait supprimer la justice ce
serait quand même pas plus mal dores et
déjà des d'ailleurs d'entrée de jeu dans
la réforme
il impose le fait qu'il faut avant
d'engager un recours avoir affaire à un
médiateur
ce qui est une expérience au canada qui
fonctionne depuis très longtemps et qui
fonctionne extrêmement bien parce que
les médiateurs sont des médiateurs
professionnels et qui essaye vraiment de
faire de la médiation du but or là ici
dans la réforme c'est des médiateurs
c'est n'importe qui c'est à dire qu'il y
aura pas d'exigence de qualification bon
deux médiateurs monde et on peut faire
oui et alors et on peut faire ça c'est
la chose qui m'étonne le plus c'est
qu'on peut faire de la médiation par
internet est en fait la médiation par
internet c'est d'interroger un médiateur
qui est en réalité un algorithme qui dit
bah oui je rentre les deux chacun deux
parties vont rentrer les données
financières enfin tout dépend du sujet
c'est aussi un dossier mais rentrer les
données
ans hier et de médiateur va dire et bien
au vu de ce tarif là si vous allez en
justice vous aurez temps donc moi je
vous conseille dans le cadre de l'agglo
gassion temps on dit et on fait pour but
un bon accord qu'un mauvais procès oui
d'accord mais là on peut on est enfin à
un bon accord c'est quand un accord est
discutée si on fait ça uniquement avec
des algorithmes traces de balles et que
donc c'est qu'en fait on traite des cas
et on ne traite pas des gens donc déjà
là il ya un vrai problème sur cette
histoire de médiation donc va falloir
obligatoirement passer par ce stade là
qui finalement soit c'est une vraie
médiation et ça sert à quelque chose
parce que là du coup ça peut
effectivement purgé avec des bonds
médiateur ça peut purger beaucoup de
contentieux
et puis ensuite eh ben on à la
suppression des tous les tribunaux
d'instance de france qui vont être
absorbés par des tj ce qui veut dire
qu'on va avoir des déserts de justice
dans alors bon paris et la banlieue
parisienne ça va aller mais après en
province ça risque d'être embêté ans
donc il y aura plus de justice de
proximité du tout alors que le tribunal
d'instance gère quand même des dossiers
qui sont des petits dossiers mais c'est
des dossiers l'occasion des petits
conflits mais c'est le quotidien
c'est le quotidien daily mais est-ce qu
est-ce que d'une façon générale pardon
il ya il n'y a pas trop de procès en
france convoité juge en effet sont
totalement débordés qu'ils ont des dd
des centaines et des centaines de
dossiers à traiter
oui c'est un déficit qu'il n'y a pas une
nécessité quand même à trouver une
alternative
oui mais est-ce à la saisine de la
justice oui mais quelle est la bonne
alternative
est-ce que l'internet l'alternative qui
est choisie c'est de couper et de faire
en sorte que le justiciable ne rencontre
plus le juge ont donc déjà en matière de
divorce
alors quand on fait un divorce amiable
maintenant passe plus par le juge
puisque c'est d'eux avocat un notaire un
peu de temps oui tout va bien mais quand
on est sur un divorce pour faute
on passe par la justice est d'abord on
passait par une audience de conciliation
ou un juge essayé dans toutes les
parties de tard c'est supprimer ça
n'existe plus maintenant ça donc on va
directement sur l'autoroute yeux durs
qui va continuer à exister
mais je trouve que c'est tout à fait
dommage parce que le juge du tribunal
d'instance avait un rôle extrêmement
important dans la régulation et dans la
proximité parce que les gens y viennent
seuls ils viennent au tribunal
d'instance ils n'ont pas forcément un
avocat et gens viennent seuls pour
parler à leurs juges
et maintenant ils ne parleront plus au
juge ils vont faire des saisines alors
un truc est pas mal c'est que pour
saisir le tgi
avant il y avait cinq modes de saisie
maintenant il y aura plus qu'un seul
mode de saisine du tgi et qui se fera
par internet également donc ça se fera
plus par voie d'assignation fera des
assignations d'automatisation pays noté
m noto mètres d'une automatisation et
puis ensuite le justiciable là pour le
personnel à la critique principale est
celle ci ensuite ya une autre critique
qui est fait
ils vont créer des tribunaux criminels
oui il à dire que on va avoir des
tribunaux criminels avec un président
qui est professionnel quatre assesseurs
qui sont professionnels et donc jury
populaire pour juger les majeures qui
n'ont jamais été condamnés dont qui sont
pas en récidive et kiri jusqu'à quinze à
vingt ans d'emprisonnement
donc la cour d'assises jusqu'à 20 ans
donc la cour d'assises va rester
uniquement pour l'heure les assassinats
ou les viols avec actes de barbarie etc
et ensuite il y aura toujours appel
devant la cour d'appel d'assises toute
manière oui mais figure le mam les
désengorger quand même laisser le temps
d'aller plus vite et d'aller plus vite
célébrité c'est d'aller plus vite
désengorge aimerait que les ladders
évoqué un problème de lenteur et de
d'engorgement il faut pas oublier une
chose c'est que ces dernières années on
a eu une tout un fils de réforme avec
notamment la suppression des justices
des tribunaux proximité tu l'as dit des
tribunaux d'instance maintenant dans
cette idée que finalement il faudrait à
familiariser les français a essayé
d'aller moins en justice
oui c'est vrai qu'on a un réflexe
contentieux très fort en france est
beaucoup trop de d'argent qui est
dépensé là dedans alors l'optique de la
dette elle est évidemment partout dans
toutes les administrations dans tous les
services publics on essaye de faire des
restrictions
néanmoins je partage l'avis de florence
sur la question c'est que à partir du
moment où on ne change pas le réflexe et
que à partir du lait français
continueront à essayer d'aller en
justice
supprimer des tribunaux n'est pas
forcément la bonne réponse dans le sens
où à partir du moment où vous en
supprimer un vous redonner sa compétence
à un autre qui lui-même vallée d'or
quatre fois plus encore et on a déjà des
tribunaux de grande instance qui sont
déjà sol humide et que j'ai fait par les
affaires qu'ils ont à traiter qui vont
courir à la faillite
1 avec maintenant on fait un parallèle
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec ce que
vous dites mais si on fait un parallèle
par exemple avec la professionnalisation
suite aux deux réformes des de droit
social où finalement on a
professionnalisé l'accès au conseil des
prud'hommes avec une requête motivée des
pièces etc
il y à 40% de baisse du contentieux
donc est ce que finalement arrivé
d'entendre y arriver plus tôt en
professionnalisant oui en empêchant les
gens d'aller pour voir oui ou pour un
non très bien sûr c'est à dire que là ça
empêchera pas les pays où les supprime
donc à plus ou moins brève direct on va
au tj mais ça n'empêchera pas donc on
pourra saisir le tgi comme on saisit cdi
donc les gens pour identité un robot
pas si on professionnalise changement
intellectuelle sur la manière d'agir
longue et il ya un problème de budget de
la justice quand même non moi maintenant
spéciale je vous écris beaucoup
d'attention et j'ai appris des choses
moi il ya deux choses que je veux dire
comment se fait-il qu'on n'ait pas fait
cette réforme avec le métier avec eux
oui mais c'est pour ça qu'on l'a jetée
jury c'est vraiment l'impression et
deuxièmement je voudrais attirer votre
attention sur un fait
la société française est fracturée
je sais tout le monde dit oui je vous
dis la société est fragile on dit à
train aujourd'hui de d'éloigner le maire
avec toutes ces intercom et où on ne
sait plus qui est à moi comme maire de
vendredi après midi
il n'est pas me demander une place en
crèche il n'est pas de demander un passe
droit pour un logement y venaient me
parler et simplement le fait que
j'écoutais d'importants biens réélu
comme dirait l'autre parce qu'il
m'aimait bien et moi je dis attention il
ne faut pas tout mettre par terre alors
peut-être que le président veut et dit
tout à l'heure vous contredire veut
réformer mais attention de ne pas encore
fragilisé la société française et je
dirais prenez pas mal que je vais dire
il ya des gens qui savent se défendre
on a quand même de notre population des
gens qui sont très éloignées reste à 7
francs en faux de france et c'est pas à
baisser
c'est pas à baisser c'est pas bien
nommé tangara tout à feu et à sang
et moi je avait un conseil à donner mon
avis je suis quand même étonné de voir
tous paitier dans la rue j'avais
rencontré les avocats hier soir et c'est
pas des gens qui descendent forcément
facile à vivre comme vous avez là mais
là c'est vrai que on a eu le projet de
loi 8 jours avant que ça arrive a légué
aucune place à station des avocats sur
des sujets d'action est absolument
attention la précipitation et ça je ne
comprends pas parce qu'il n'est pas
tomber dans ce travers sur les autres et
font les limites des trois générations
sur les zones pourquoi lorient n'a pas
pourquoi la alors simplement qu'il était
valable il y avait nécessité quand même
faire évoluer justice ou par le bas mais
pas par le bas parce que je discutais
hier à paris avec des avocats de
versailles ailleurs un ancien bâtonnier
il est d'accord sur certaines vous avez
sur certaines réformes
mais attention la proximité du maire la
proximité du juge là parce que c'est
elle qui avant c'était le directeur
d'école on lui met une claque qui jamais
ils donnent une mauvaise de notes à
votre enfant
bon il y avait lui récusé moi même si le
président a été aux arts la religion
catholique c'est fini il y avait le
médecin médecin moi j'ai été malade
quand je suis rentré d'un voyage
il restait trois minutes et demie chez
moi bon c'est pas que je veux critiquer
le médecin j'en ai déjà mais moi je
défends cette proximité
alors vous allez me dire quand j'ai
étudié ce que vous avez ce qu'on a dit
tout à l'heure au niveau du canada il ya
même d'autres choses au niveau de d'un
treuil et compagnie tout à fait
attention la société française n'est pas
là mais même si nous parler la même
langue la halle est fragile il faut
d'écouté et juste avant la médiation
permet d'écouter à temps plein
l'objectif de la médiation pas que je
dise à présent le oui à une réforme non
une réforme qui est parfait avec le
professe que c'est pas une limite des
ministres ils viennent de la société
civile où je pense à nicole belloubet
ministre de la justice
plusieurs font berner ensemble de
problèmes de constatation les réformes
de concertation et dans la concertation
qui s'est rarement raté
oui j'ai eu je comprends pas non plus
parce que même très souvent la main
tendue en plus c'est pas très compliqué
maintenant comblé
[Musique]
c'est peut-être aussi des sujets qu'ils
ne maîtrisent pas totalement il a
peut-être fait aussitôt terme en
confiance à une partie de son équipe
ça va être un truc assez technique
oblige désormais avant d'essayer de
concerter avec les voir ils sont
intéressés y a pas véritablement de
rapport il ya quand même de bonnes
choses notamment qu'ils aient que le
travail d'intérêt général est inscrite
maintenant thème plein alors qu'avant
c'était un accessoire qui pouvaient être
utilisés non mais regardez c'est bien
c'est vrai que deux sondes a conscience
qu'il faut réformer la chose pourquoi
les femmes pourquoi ne pas en parler
ensemble au fait il ya tout à l'heure
vous parler mais je pourrai juger des
ministres
surtout pas le premier vient de ma
famille mais attention
entre théorie et pratique
attention la théorie ou faire un beau
discours vous dites formidable et puis
quand on l'appliqué on s'aperçoit qu'il
ya toutes sortes de difficultés
problèmes voilà et les politiques savent
ça peut-être
écoutez moi j'ai appris la série 5 gt
club des autres mais la sagesse est venu
tout au dos et a dit oui alors il ya
d'autres exemples aussi par exemple de
pour simplifier les choses quand sur les
pensions alimentaires
normalement quand il ya un problème sur
la pension alimentaire ont saisi c'est
le juge maintenant si la caf
c'est donc c'est la caf déjà qui n'est
pas du tout encombré déjà c'est très
facile d'avoir la caf au téléphone quand
on a un problème mais là il va falloir
saisir la caf et c'est le président de
la caf qui va être décidé de la
modification de la pension alimentaire
c'est quand même un peu aberrant fin
désengorge un autre organisme pour que
des gens qui déjà ça un mot sur la
des questions qui appellent qui sera
sans doute abordée dans l'interview sur
bfm celui de la laïcité
il ya eu ce discours devant les évêques
de france où emmanuel macron parler de
maltraitance au fond de la religion
qu'est ce que vous en avez pensé ce que
c'est une atteinte à la laïcité ou pas
certains la suite mois que catholique je
le revendique pour pratiquer au mans
mais cathodique
oui je pense qu'il y avait à revoir les
choses vis-à-vis de cette religion pas
beaucoup d'autres religions dans ce pays
tout en tous les jours à chaque instant
de regarder mais d'un autre côté
moi je suis catholique personnellement
j'étais maire laïc
j'étais sénateur laïque j'ai été vice
président du conseil général
c'était conseil général à l'époque des
yvelines laïque attention quand vous
avez c'est voyez ce que je veux dire
vous avez vous votre engagement
personnel ça réaliser des choses cet
idiot et d'un autre à la différence il
aa laïcité quelque chose de très
important dans l'équilibré de balle
je termine dans l'équilibré global de la
société je le mets dedans
attention à ne pas transgresser ce qui a
été construit et qui est solide
je suis 100% de votre avis mais je
rebondis sur un des vos éléments de
langage qu'on me dit mais on parle
beaucoup des autres religions on ne
parle que d autres religions et va dire
toute la journée on nous explique qu'il
faut organiser l'islam de france qu'il
faut s'occuper des imams qu'il faut
s'occuper de leur formation qu'il faut
s'occuper des mosquées qui faisaient
occupé en est et ça ça ne choque
personne apparemment et tout d'un coup
il ya un dîner du président la
république avec le
le gotha de l'église catholique et là
tout d'un coup tu es tout le monde plus
des cris d'orfraie dhr mais c'est
monstrueux c'est scandaleux c'est un
[Musique]
discours il n'y avait rien de choquant
c'est vrai que c'est vrai qu'il ya un
lien est à venir ou alors on ne parle
plus jamais de l'islam
nulle part et à ce moment-là arrêtons de
parler des catholiques très bien mais
habana
non mais il est issu le mans et audi
doublement il est temps de latence
semble-t-il aux racines chrétiennes de
la forêt mais tout le monde avait peur
de le dire c'est bien
kamerhe président à ça alors maintenant
j'appelle pour bfm
je sois pas là donc bien fait à shrek
j'aurais du mal à toucher j'appelle à ce
qu'ils reviennent sur ce qu'on est en
train de dire il était en mal de ré je
pense que la lame attendu qu'il a donnée
est positive vrai bon maintenant il faut
bien qu'ils nous expliquent dans ses
responsabilités à la tête de notre pays
qui doit être laïque il doit respecter
tout ça parce qu on a parlé des cats
home on pourrait parler aussi des
protestants et de tout ce que vous
voulez un bon voilà j'appelle à j'avais
dit tout à l'heure vous l'avez dit
vous-même europe
et puis aussi que mayotte alors l'europe
vraiment trop le temps d'en parler mais
je voudrais juste une chose je pense que
quand il dit que l'état peut entendre
des choses qui viennent de l'église ça
n'a rien de choquant on sait pas
contrôler les systèmes va pas dire
justement délit mais c'est la remise en
cause du mari dix ans pour
l'étape entendre personnes exilées
production est importante mais là où il
a peut-être franchi une toute petite
ligne c'est quand il a dit que les
chrétiens doivent s'engager
or l'état devra imposer quelque chose à
l'égard ne doit pas imposer quelque
chose à l'état
il devait enfin à mon avis c'est là où
il a peut-être franchi la ligne sur le
problème de laïcité quand il dit les
chrétiens doivent s'engager
moi je crois qu'il a un peu franchi la
ligne je sens notamment par rapport à sa
posture vous avez parlé de l'ordre et
l'ordre républicain qui est important à
maintenir surtout dans ces périodes on a
parlé dans notre dernier paf
antisémitisme de problèmes avec les
fiches et s etc
donc on est dans des spas des guerres de
religion mais on est quand même dans des
guerres de groupuscules qui sont en
train de se faire beaucoup de mal et je
crois qu'il y a oui ben de oui voilà on
est on est quand même c'est pour ça tu
pars tu dis qu'on parle beaucoup d'
islam de france je pense qu'on en parle
parce qu'on a des problèmes avec ce type
de religion et de formation qu'on n'a
pas forcément avec l'église catholique
donc pourquoi parler de là où on n'a pas
de problème là où on a des problèmes
avec d'autres religions et je crois
aussi que ce qu'il faut afficher c'est
un message d'unité pour justement ne pas
monter les religions les unes contre les
autres alors non soutenir aucune c'est
le postulat de la laïcité justement pour
essayer de faire que les religions
s'harmonisent entre elles en donnant une
main tendue à une religion qui c'est
vrai n'a pas été sous les spotlights ces
derniers temps c'est c'est une bonne
chose mais il a peut-être été un petit
peu trop loin dans la main tendue
notamment en dix ans les rapports entre
l'église et l'état ne sont pas ce que je
souhaiterais ou etc je crois que il doit
il avait refusé notamment de s'approcher
du cercueil de johnny on sent un signe
de croix pour essayer d'éviter
d'afficher cette procédure
je crois à la demande
sa femme témoin de faire la fête et donc
vous voyez là je trouve qu'il a un petit
peu franchissent la ligne rouge ce sur
quoi à mon avis connaissant un peu le
tollé que ça à fait sûrs dimanche il
reviendra mais il ya une forme de
dépassement à mon sens soissons l'ancien
président qui qui publie donc les leçons
du pouvoir alors quoi aborder tous tous
les hommes et est ce que est ce que
comme ça on penser que cette impression
on voit bien il a même du mal à défendre
son bilan aujourd'hui mais est ce que
pour vous cette impression qu'on a un
peu mais estimé sco finalement juste
devant moi beaucoup voyagé avec lui tu
as un homme charmant qui vous écoutent
ils vous respectent son bilan et conan
ans pour garder leur maman serey die on
s'aperçoit avec maquereau au pouvoir son
bilan est quand même pas formidable ces
histoires personnelles de moi qui défend
la femme j'ai été voilà voilà un exemple
moi je qui défend la femme de faire un
communiqué pour dire que la compagne
c'est quelque chose que deuxièmement il
a fait un livre qui est absolument
normal pas de pas de celui ci en
attendant il y aurait pas dire qu'on est
là devrais pas dire ça et effectivement
devrais pas dire ça
ils étaient subjugués par les
journalistes messieurs il adorerait
déjeuner avec eux pour le livre il a
vomi de la transparence mais je pense
qu'il faut pas tout rayé parce que c'est
facile en france on passe au suivant
mais quand on voit le skull
le président actuel souhaite faire on
s'aperçoit quand même beaucoup de
faiblesses et je dirais même un manque
de courage sur certains dossiers que je
pourrais donner les uns près des autres
moi je regardais les choses il était il
voulait très consensuel comme vous
partiez socialiste de trouver la
synthèse je voulais passer dans toulouse
car j'ai fait moi je reste jacky loti
l'ancien président
j'en dirai pas plus non je crois qu'il a
perdu 2 les deux premières années à
vouloir concilier tout le monde et donc
du coup ça ça va entraîner un manque de
clarté dans la politique qui a été menée
et on a pensé qu'il ya eu un tournant
après quand tu es eu le pacte de
responsabilité alors que s'il l'avait
annoncé d'emblée les choses auraient
sans doute c'était plus clair
oui mais il ya des choses qu'il a pu
pour que par exemple emmanuel macron a
poursuivi notamment en matière de droit
du travail parce qu'avec déjà françois
hollande avait fait beaucoup puisqu'on a
eu la loire et de semaine qui ce qui
multiplié le special one comme rick est
mal passé parce qu a pas eu de
concertation du tout et alors que on
retrouve maintenant dans la loi travail
puisque maintenant elle est c'est une
loi on retrouve là cela louise 8 la
suite l'esprit de ce qu'avait fait sous
françois hollande qui a eu cice il ya eu
des choses en fait pas tout mettre à la
poubelle quand je vois moi j'ajouterais
aussi que en tant qu'homme en tout cas
par rapport à l' on a parlé d'un
président chanceux quand on a parlé d'
emmanuel macron tout à l'heure je pense
qu'on peut parler d'un président
malchanceux pour pour qualifier françois
hollande sur l'aéroport notamment
mais pas seulement il a quand même connu
des frondeurs dans sa pile de diable
climat décidemment marqué mon
quinquennat
hirai où il raconte t il racontant du
sud son premier voyage avec will va voir
merkel le jour de son investiture
et si l'une est trompé donné il n'y a
pas un type qui met les doigts dans la
musique il y avait un parapluie je
trouvais un parapluie c'est pas une
honte
il est là et le nul in à dessein cet été
lors d'une finale avant par les valeurs
de la sphère leonarda ou l'allemagne
même l'image de la france l'image et la
fonction présidentielle en a pris un
coup tiré et il manage la vôtre très
vite c'est vrai parce que je n'ai pas
longtemps qu'il est là donc tout est
paru rejeter totalement des regrets non
en tout cas le livre et quand on veut
comprendre ce qu'est le pouvoir est
peut-être la solitude du pouvoir parce
qu'il parle beaucoup de sa solitude
le livret est passionnant à lire ça
s'appelle donc tes leçons de pouvoir
sécher stocks et ses 2 françois hollande
merci infiniment à la bourre nac ce que
vous allez faire un long voyage
si vous voulez vous en parle et qu'on
vous reviendrai ça sera avec grand
plaisir je ne cache pas je pars en iran
jeu plutôt visiter la perse
d'ailleurs c'est un j'avais 19 ans 20
ans c'était vraiment un coin du monde
qui m'intéressait et je réalise avec mon
épouse et des amis et j'en suis très
heureux mais je suis très heureux aussi
d'avoir été invité
est ce que c'est un pays passionnant si
vous voulez bien d'en parler et bien si
vous m'aviez je faisais cadet et mon
frère cadet pardon et non faire le veni
à très vite pour un nouveau pas fait
[Musique]